Hello, everybody. My name is Markiplier, and welcome back to Cuphead.
So we're almost done with this game, which means that this might just be...
where the end is! Inkwell hell. Why would I go there?
Why did we and Mugman go there in the first place? That seems like a bad place to be.
Hmm, alright! Well, into the casino I go. Ooh, hey!
Yeah, I don't like that place. All bets are off!
There's no option for simple difficulty.
You have to do this...
Super strongy. "Well, lookie here,"
"you actually pulled it off."
"But you've made me lose a bet and for that you ain't seeing the boss just yet."
"We're gonna play a little game first!"
That's.... Why? What, just 'cause you're a shitty person?
Well, you're making this happen. This ain't my fault.
Uh oh!
Uhh, Yes? Wow! Oh!
That wasn't a good thing was it? That.. Oh!
Announcer: Good day for a swell battle!
What?!
Announcer: It's on!!!
What?! Uh oh!
That ain't good!
Oh shit, okay? Well, this is weird.
Ahh shit. Whoa, I'm not paying attention. Oh jeez!
Oh wow! Okay, wow.
Whew!
This is gonna be a doozy. I can already tell, this is gonna be a doozy!
How about I don't? What if I don't?
Alright fine, I will...
Health up! Oh!
Okay, ahhh!
Okay, all right. I get it. Is it like a... Is this like a...
Rigmarole whole smash battle of a bunch of different things?
Aw shit, goddamn it. I do not pay attention to that.
Goddamn it. I'm not paying attention to the right things.
Oh, shit, god. I've been hit by everything.
Oh, fuck!
Every single thing I got hit by, every single thing.
Wow, that is ridiculous. Okay, here we go.
Alright.
Oh, hey, you're different.
Oh, jeez, just as time as I learned something, I got to learn something else, huh?
I see how it is. Whoa. He's dead now.
Oh, I see what I need to do. That's horrible.
This is horrible.
I don't like you. I don't like you at all.
At least you guys seem to have relatively simple mechanics.
Oh, hate that. Please tell me that's all you do.
Please tell me that's literally all you do. You've got no originality to you.
That's it. This is all there is.
Seems like it might be. Yeah, is this the only thing?
Is this the only thing you got?
Hey! That is the only thing you got! Hell yeah!
Oh, yeah, baby, okay, oh jeez. Oh God, Oh, dice man.
Don't do that. Don't do that. So it is a gambit.
I gotta like-- I gotta-- oh, I see what I gotta do. Okay.
All right, one two three, one two three, one two-- boink.
Oh! Ahh..
I see. I see. It is a game. Oh, okay. I get it.
Yeah, whoa, I don't like thi.
Whoops, shit. I don't know what this is gonna do
Yeah, I don't really like that one very much oh
Hey, baby
All right, well, I'm doing pretty good. I don't know what that drink one threw me so hard
It was just like it was it was really weird it shouldn't have been that bad.
Okay, if I can just get a one
A one or a three.
one one
one one one
Yeah, health up, baby
Give it give it give it give it give it come on.
What do you got? What do you got you got nothing?
That's what you got. you got nothin.
Uh oh, I don't like this guy oh
Uh oh, that ain't good.
Okay well, that's a bunch of rabbit skulls very morbid
But you know it is what it is
ha ha ha
You didn't count on the fact that I can just go-woahh-
es-cah-peh out of anything, did ya?
Ha ha, missed me.
Oh, come on! I-I definitely balley-hooed that!
I balley-hooed the balley-hoo out of that!
I just moved my camera, I'm sorry all right there we go.
Nobody saw anything right?
Nobody peered behind the curtain.
No one saw anything devious happening, did ya? No.
All right.
How about a two?
two(x7)
It speeds up.
two(x3)
TWO! Got it! Yeah, baby!
Ahaha, ohoho
All right how about three? How bout three?
Three(x7)
Ah, shoot
Three (x3)
No
No, what am I doing?
Three, THREE!
Yeah, baby!
Okay, goddamn. Oh,
Start Over or Fin.
I don't like that at all.
Oh, I don't like that at all.
Oh boy. Yeah, I don't like you at all, either.
Woah? (x5)
Hey woah woah woah.
Easy, up there, ya laddo.
Well this is weird and sad.
Why is this, why is this thing so sad?
I don't know what to make of this.
Very-Ohh!
I see! Oh, I see. I see.
Oh, it's a matching game.
Ah. Not quite.
Okay, ahh.
Good thing I'm so smart.
Monkey: Gyahh!
Mark: Gah-bahh!!!
Uh oh, wuh oh.
Yeesh.
I don't like that.
Ha-badooski! Ok.
Got that. All right. Now you're dead.
Okay. What is this?
god? I haven't seen that one yet. Oh hey got it. All right
Hoodili-do. Well.
Oh! Whoa whoa okay? What do we got here?
I saw that over here. Nah shit. It was over here some
Yeah, that was it you got that
Yehhh!!
Okay-wuh so sad!
Ok, you, ah, saw you over?
Wa-oh, here?
No no no he was up here.
No, he was down here wasn't he
Oh geez oh, no you are there
Yeesh. Okay, this guy's not so bad.
Auahhh, I say, as I almost get hit.
Okay, all right, okay, all right.
Okay, what do we got
You and you are here? Yes? Okay
There we go(x3)
Uh oh(x5)
Ohhhea!! I don't like that.
I don't like that at all.
Okay, there you go, there you go.
And last-oo, a slappy
Slapp-e-doo-dah
Oh boy yer gonna be super fast ain't ya?
and super annoying? Oh, no, you're not that fast!
You were faster before!
Well, get dead.
Oh-OOH! That was not fun.
Hey! Got 'em!
Ohh, smash your own head together, that, you shouldn't be doing that.
I mean, if you want to do that I guess I can't stop you.
Okay, if I roll a three, I'm done.
If I roll a three, I'm done.
Three (x8)
There we go, that was it.
Three (x4)
GOOOO-aaand I'm done!!!
Uh oh, uh oh, oh wait, wait, no.
Wait, no, wait. What the hell?
Oh, jeez, that's not fun at all.
I didn't know that was gonna be immediately going for that.
Awww, no.
Wow (x6)
Wow (x5)
Holy shit.
Two!
Wow, wow, wowie wow.
Wow.
Okay, this is gonna suck.
This whole thing is gonna suck.
All right. What do you got, what do you got?
Oh, I don't like that.
Oh, I hate that. Hate that in fact.
Why is everyone dead at this casino, also?
I feel like that should be something that people are slightly perturbed about.
People should be a little concerned.
I mean- oh shit. Oh god damn it.
Any hit is, like, gonna be super bad.
There we go. Okay.
God. This is gonna be rough.
Rough and tumble, but that's amazing.
They-they built
However many tiles there are bosses
for this, like, wow, that is amazing.
Okay, three or a two.
Three (x5)
Okay, at least I'm good at hitting the dice.
But, somethin tells me I'm gonna bone it up.
Announcer: It's on!!!
Shit. Oh, goddamnit.
Okay, I know I had my super there, but it wasn't a good place to use it.
It was just, ah, it was really rough and tumble.
Okay, if I get a three get a three,
Three (x7)
Okay, safe.
I want a two. (x3)
two-two-two
Two!
Got it. Aye-yai-yai.
Let's hope the next one is something that I can use.
I don't know if I got this one last time.
I probably did, but,
Nope! Haven't seen this one.
Alright, gonna play it safe with this.
Oh boy, play it safe, play-
oh why?!? That is. What is-are you kidding me?!?
I just happened to be standing in the way-
Oh boy, this is awful.
Wah! Oh boy.
Oh boy, hate this! Hate this. Hate this. Okay.
I'm gonna use this, but I don't know how well it's gonna go.
Ah, sh-I got hit. I got hit again. I got hit a-fucking-gain.
Ah, oh boy. That was useless. That was so useless.
Oh, this is a bad one to get.
This was a bad one to get.
It's not that bad, I guess, but,
Aw, jeez, it's still like-Ewahh!
gross (x6)  very gross (x3)
Don't like that. Gross gross gross gross.
It's pretty much anything is bad at this point to get.
God, I got hit twice there. Ugh, I'm so boned.
Okay, gotta get a two, and then got to get a two.
Two and two.
Two, got it. Okay, then I just can't get a one!
Okay, let's aim for a two just in case it's stupid
Two (x8)
Got it, okay.
Announcer: This match will get red-hot. Now, go!
What? No, no, no, no
No way, I had that.
Oh, my god, are you kidding me?
Holy shit. This one's gonna be fucking brutal.
Okay. Wow, alright. Well, three? three.
Alright, I've done this one before,
it's just the cigarette guy, yeah.
There we go. Okay, first boss down.
First boss down, I got my super.
I should have changed out my super for the other thing, but,
Alright (x6)
Get a two. Get a two. Gotta get a two.
Okay, got a two.
Ok, this is fine.
I'll try to do it, but I don't think it's gonna do much.
But, might as well cuz what else am I doing, right?
Oh nooo.
No, no oh no.
Oh, that's bad.
Oh, that's bad. That was so stupid of me
I imagine that this guy,
this guy probably gives most of the players of this game the most grief.
Because holy shit. This is set up for brutality.
Oh god, okay, gotta get a three.
A three, a three, a two, and a three.
Three, three,
Hoo! That was almost a two, that was almost a two, okay.
Gotta get a two now.
Two, okay, got a two.
I've done this one- I think this is the cue ball.
This is the cue ball, right?
Just gotta dodge.
Dodge (x6)
Dodge like the dickens. (x2)
Okay, dodge like the dickens.
Easy peasy (x2)
Off tempo. (x9)
Hey! Okay, alright.
We've got five health. Five.
And there's a route where we can just get us safe
And then we can go right into the last one, even though it's bullshit.
We all know it. I know it, you know it.
I just can't get a three.
Two (x3)
Oof, that would've been a one.
Two (x5)
No! No! No! NOOO! Oh, no. Oh, no
Well. It's fine. Okay, cuz most of this is clear. Okay.
That's not so bad, three, it didn't reset.
Three, three, okay. Two, got it.
Then a three.Three!
Okay, then a two. Two!
Okay, then a three,
Two or three (x3)
Three. Okay, all right then just a one.
I'm pretty sure it won't loop me back if I do.
I'm pretty sure anything at this point is gonna be one.
One, one, okay.
Announcer: This match will get red-hot! And begin!
Okay, that's how you do it.
Okay, that's one hilth-health point down.
Ow, shit, god dammit!
God dammit, god damn. He's just bleeding me dry.
Nooo, no. No.
Shit, I'm so boned
Hey! Yes!!! Yes! Yes! Yes!
FUCK you!! Fuck you! Get Rekt!!
Your stupid hands can cry all they want!
Fuck you! Fuck yeah! Fuck yeah! Fuck yeah!
Ohh shit!
eyeah!! Whew.
Oh, boy, that one took the longest...so far, I think.
Ugh, 20 minutes on that bad boy.
Woooooo!!
Oh yeah, okay, B! Alright, so.
I don't think I'm gonna be able to beat the devil in this episode
So I'm going to save that for the next episode.
That was an arduous journey, but it was worthy journey
So thank you everybody so much for watching.
I'm gonna finish this up in one more episode.
I wanted to dedicate a whole episode to it because I don't know how long it's gonna take.
If that one took 20 minutes, next one might take an hour.
So, thank you everybody so much for watching and as always I will see you in the next video.
bye-bye
*epic outro music*